[Musik]
herzlich willkommen sallys welt und
heute gibt es keinen koch und kein bug
video es gibt ein neues video und bauern
und ich möchte euch einfach zeigen was
welches auf dem bau alles alleine machen
was wir mit unserem freund zusammen
machen die ganzen veränderungen und
heute mit einem ganz ganz besonderen
raum und zwar sind wir in unserem büro
und zwar ascend manche von euch haben
wir es gleich ein arbeitszimmer wo man
einfach den ganzen schriftverkehr
bearbeitet und dieses büro ist dann ein
bisschen wenig platz haben wir haben
wirklich zu klein gebaut es wirklich so
dass zeigen wie man anderen video haben
wir uns gedacht wir aus dem bürger auch
gleichzeitig im gästezimmer machen und
da das nicht so ein typisches büro sein
dass die leute sich unter die gäste
ließen bei uns zu besuch sind die
freunde die vielleicht im tag- und zu
übernachten sich nicht wie im büro
eingesperrt fühlen haben wir uns gedacht
oder hab ich mir gedacht mach' ich
irgendwas ganz ganz besonders ins büro
rein
das heißt die wandgestaltung sei es die
modellierung und dessen bis deswegen
dieses video heute habe ein paar
freunden dabei die mir dabei helfen
werden dieses büro zu gestalten
und ich möchte jetzt allgemein normal
dass bürozeiten und sage euch ganz genau
was ich vorhabe und im laufe des videos
seht ihr alles wie wir das alles hier
verwirklichen
ok wie gesagt hier haben wir das büro es
halt ein bisschen hier drin sind
natürlich keine möbel drin
die wände sind noch nicht verputzt es
ist noch ein teppich drängten gar nix
und deswegen halte so ziemlich und ich
möchte euch einmal zeigen hier zum
beispiel an diese wand das sein was sie
hier machen kommt mineral putzfrau von
snuko pompei
da hole ich nachher roberto belge
roberto spezialist dafür das ist was
ganz ganz edles aber ich möchte von dem
zu viel verraten dann hier direkt an
dieser wand hier
hier wird nachher mein schreibtisch sein
oder sally schreibtisch kommt drauf an
wer
mehr zu tun hat hier an dieser wand
mache ich diese holzvertäfelungen und
zwar es ist ein richtiges holz also es
ist kein fehler
mir ist es ganz ganz wichtig dass wir in
allen räumen eigentlich fast
ausschließlich nur natürliche baustoffe
verwenden das heißt es soll holz sein es
sollte keinen kunststoff kein plastik
sein und der mineral putz deshalb berufs
arm sein
der soll der soll natürlich sein da mal
was ganz ganz tolles an diese wand hier
kommt auch die holzvertäfelung hin
dann geht es weiter an dieser wand hier
da machen wir auch in holz hinten ein
richtiges vollholz ihn deswegen nachher
auch noch dieser raum ist eigentlich
diese vertretung ist daher entstanden
wir haben den raum im bauch größer
gemacht eigentlich war hier in bc
geplant dann wäre aber zu klein gewesen
jetzt aber noch weiter gezogen und hier
waren die ganzen lyc und die ganzen
wasserleitungen und ich müsste mir jetzt
verstecken
deswegen haben wir den vorraum gemacht
ist cool ist jetzt einfach wenn man das
hier verteilt haben werde ich hier das
hier mit leder überziehen so dass man
sich nachher später auch hier hinsetzen
kann
ok diese wand machen wenn roberto
ebenfalls das video zu call for papers
sieht so edel aus das ist wirklich
genial und hier wird nachher ist ein
schrank stehen und mit den beiden
schranks einfach so ihr zieht daran und
aus diesen schrank wird nachher im bett
als eine ganz ganz tolle geschichte
und dann haben wir büro arbeitszimmer
mit dem gästezimmer frei also ein ganz
ganz tolles video ihr wäre dass
verschiedene freunde von mir sehen der
roberto wird nachher da sein
da alex wird nachher da sein vielleicht
auch im juni noch kommen und wie gesagt
von anfang bis ende werden wir im ganzen
video mitverfolgen können die so ein
zimmer entsteht okay jetzt zeigen wir
einfach mal was ich in dem robert um
vorhabt und jetzt gehen wir ganz kurz
das studio ich zeig mal eine wand wird
so gut wie mit einer beton technik wie
das aussehen könnte
komik und zwar hier haben auch schon
eine art von stoke homepage immer das
ist nur eine ganz andere technik das
wird auch mit mit in diesen kaufen
aufgezogen nur hass nach eine folie die
du abschießen oder hast du diese beton
optik das haben wir hier zum beispiel in
der küche gemacht sie ganz ganz cool
daraus aber wie gesagt im büro planen
etwas ganz ganz anders gehen wir mal
kurz zum robert ohne zeigt euch was will
er ganz genau planen
so auch jetzt im roberto bei uns hier im
büro und ihr habt uns gesehen
diese diese beton technik sind richtig
cool aus und genau das gleiche nur etwas
edler möchte meint jetzt in diesem raum
ihr machen dem robert zusammen
wie gesagt es war ganz ganz toll ist ist
ein mineral beton den mineral kann ich
erklären ist ein mineral kurz wird in
italien hergestellt sprich aus
vulkangestein ist ermitteln stadt
pompeji jedem bekannt genau
ja die wurde unter vulkanasche mit
graphen geschäfte wieder richtig
gebildet
ja ich habe ja noch ich habe auf jeden
fall es geruhsam und es ist einer der
ersten punkte überhaupt der das siegel
blauer engel bekommen hat das berufs auf
und deswegen sagen wir verarbeiten
natürliche materialien über jenes
material gibt ein geruch ab wenn er viel
kunststoff wie plastik habe nichts bei
euch irgendwo im haus dritten liga als
er beim pick reinlaufen oder beim
freimarkt haben wir kein held gegen
freimarkt aber genau so riecht deswegen
wollen wir ganz ganz natürliche
materialien haben und da magst du
wirklich super billig das ideale weil
wir schon in anderen räumen auch schon
verarbeitet haben bei der verarbeitung
gibt es ein paar sachen zu beachten du
hast ja auch extra einen kurs gemacht
ich habe mehrere kurse gemacht und
unsere erfahrung spricht jetzt dafür was
ich aber noch erwähnen wollte das ganze
ding ist super geeignet für allergiker
also wie gesagt hatte ich alles
mineralisch ökologisch umweltbewusst nun
also allergiker perfekt auch im
wohnbereich alles tipptopp euch keine
sorgen machen ja ok und wie gesagt wir
fangen jetzt an mich mal die
das heißt wie gesagt ihr könnt es
vielleicht nicht alleine machen dann
brauchst du ein bisschen üben dazu ich
habe schon mehrere wände nicht nur bei
uns auch privaten roberto einige
baustellen schon gemacht ja ja und zwar
keinen schwarzen stellen nun eher als
offizieller als offiziell
und wie gesagt das musst du schnell
verarbeiten können eines
trocknungszeiten dinge wie die beachten
muss aber wie gesagt wir zeigen euch mal
wie es gemacht genau alles klar
so habe das material auf uns war desto
sie so trocken aus in puderzucker ist
ganz ganz fein gemahlen
das ist die farbe sp 31 etwas dunkler
weil ich finde einfach also meine
persönliche meinung ist einfach nur
wieder töne ist ein bisschen edler aus
und deswegen habe ich diese farbe
entschieden
und wie gesagt was wir jetzt mit roberto
zusammen machen ist folgendes im mission
ist einfach ich nicht bewerten
und es wichtig ist immer nur kleine
mengen an zu löschen weil das musst du
es richtig schnell verarbeiten wenn es
ein schönes material schnell trocken und
brüchen und zwar haben hier wasser drin
und ganz ganz wichtig ist hier kein
wohnzimmer wenden was hat meistens
einzel mit drin und es reagiert dann
deswegen wirklich ganz normales
leitungswasser nehmen und hier dann
gerade rein lernt und jetzt ist halt
wichtig da müsste ein bisschen ahnung
haben das muss eine sämige konsistenz
lange haben das hat er wirklich wenn er
den kurs gemacht habe wisse was ist was
ich damit meine
und das tue was da rein werfen und uns
einfach mal andere okay ich sehe auch
ich mache das jetzt ohne handschuhe weil
es ist komplett natürlich das ist ganz
wichtig dass man immer ein bisschen
erschüttert
es sah ganz schön und ab und zieht man
den bläschen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
umso länger man rückt umso schneller
wird und man merkt jetzt hier
es ist eigentlich robert vor richtig
gesagt das ist wie als willst du denn
viele firmen auch mit philadelphia
frischkäse musste so ungefähr sagt und
jetzt hat ungewollt komisch aus aber
jetzt ist es richtig konsistenz und
jetzt müssen wir uns für eine jetzt nur
zwei ist das ist sofort angewandt okay
wenn wir jetzt auch dabei
dabei haben ist das ist ganz ganz
schnell geht der leo kannst damit kommt
das auch mal die kamera lego
einzuschüchtern
so jetzt haben wir das ding an die wand
bevor es trocknet okay also kommt
dennoch leo brauchen heißt loch leer aus
dem grund weil er immer leicht an den
tisch es hat so wichtig ist immer die
rede
edelstahl traufen zu verwenden jede
stadt ganz ganz weder wenn sie nicht
rosten können wiederverwendet natürlich
und wir müssen richtig schön glas sein
das heißt dass diese diese handwerker
werkzeuge müssen immer absolut absolut
gepflegt so genau
okay da gibt es in ganz polen trägt beim
aufziehen das kind jedem auch immer von
unten nach oben von links nach rechts
die technik lebt davon dass sie das
endlich kreuz und quer geht und es gibt
nachher diese richtig tollen effekte
[Musik]
ok leon kannst du ganz kurz
und ich bin gleicher leistung weniger
zwischen morath blond und süß minecraft
wäre ja also ich mache jetzt nicht
weiter weil ich bin kann meine hände
waschen melden und völlig sauber
arbeiten machte schon jungs
[Musik]
ich bin sozusagen der jürgen klopp der
baubranche ich muss den leo motivieren
dass er es dann richtig macht was wir
hier auch haben ist ganz cool und zwar
das ist nicht nur für ihn das ist hier
das ist roberto mit 2 trafen in der hand
dessen zwei spezielle brauchen was er ja
und damit für edle flächen und zwar
schreibt er über diesen putz drüber und
zieht dadurch die reibung mit
feuchtigkeit dann ist es folgte waren
ein gesicht also sprich ein bild genau
jede wand für sich immer ein unikat
ja und jetzt seht ihr jetzt macht er
robert der streicher nicht rüber ins all
um die feuchtigkeit und macht die band
richtig klasse das heißt wenn ihr
nachher mit der hand drüber fakt ist es
glatt hinein kriegen co
einige vater als will über eine
eisfläche drüber geht
[Musik]
wir sehen natürlich wirklich italienisch
schwedisch spanische badisches handwerk
oder das richtig passt oder nicht immer
noch nicht weiß was genau jetzt mal ohne
spaß
scheiß auf leon max lasst uns zusammen
hören ist
42 scheiß auf die reise gemacht können
gleich einstellen
also wird in zukunft mit roberto nur
noch banken also in 2 und braucht dann
ruft los und wenn er sich oft rufen uns
portionierten kaffee ablösung
so ist gut mehr vögel
[Musik]
also jetzt haben wir jetzt aufgezogen
habe ist so komplett abgezogen und das
nächste land muss jetzt mal zwölf
stunden trocknen die ganze feuchtigkeit
draußen ist und dann gehen wir mit einer
nase über es gibt verschiedene lasuren
und ich habe mich etwas ganz ganz
ähnlich entschieden dass es nachher wird
es noch dunkler einiges noch dunkler und
es bekommen glanzmann es noch poliert
und das ist nicht cool so sagen ich
würde jetzt sagen dass einstein war eine
richtig coole steigen dann würde ich
sagen ja und das haben danach hervor
und in der zwischenzeit tue mir zb auch
hier
ich habe ja gesagt das thema verkleiden
dass meine alexis zeigen euch
wir haben mal hier diese bretter
hingenommen und zwar hat das sind das
ist ein parkett von kers das ist ein
vollholz er merkt auch richtig gut mal
das ist richtig dick etwas ganz ganz
besonderes und damit verkleidungen wir
dann die sind diesen diesen korpus hier
und hier unten und hier unten machen
doch jeder hin und ließ dann richtig
genial aus und einen tag später kommen
dann die möbel und mitgehen zusammen mit
es wirklich ein cooles büro und cooles
gäste ziehen und hier haben wir das
fertige produkt eigentlich die fertige
wand ich hab mich jetzt gegen lassen
entschieden ja nicht nur fein abgesperrt
und abgeschliffen und jetzt jetzt
wirklich so aus
und das kann man richtig tolle sache
noch an jemand dran machen ich mache
noch einen coolen spruch noch drauf
macht vielleicht noch im bild drauf ich
habe mir überlegt ob ich ludwig erhard
hin mache als bild eine ganz tolle
geschichte jetzt ein anderes mal
und auch hier mal ganz ganz cool kann
ganz toll hingekriegt und beim nächsten
video zeigt euch über das thema alles
eingerichtet haben wir die
wandgestaltung gemacht haben und wie das
büro innerhalb ganz fertig aussieht
[Musik]
einfach sally it's tea time
meine freundin sabine und ich wir hatten
ein richtig schönes mittels wochenende
in großbritannien da gab es richtig
tolle köstlichkeiten ich möchte die
urlaubsgefühle wieder zurück banken um
ihre freundin zu überraschen was sally
buch very british eine königliche
theater und gebäck bei der beute steht
dafür muss ich tatsächlich wie seine
kollegen einfach sally sonntag 16 uhr
bei vox